but what i want to start with are basic
end games and i want to teach you a
couple of end games that you basically
have to know
and through the lens of that i'm going
to introduce you to some basic endgame
principles
okay maybe that sounds fine um now
basically when we were looking at
mates right elementary mates like rook
against king and queen against king
those are end games as well like i was
teaching you
types of end games it's just that those
fell under the category of basic mates
and now i'm going to teach you actual
end games and today we'll only do one
type of end game i don't want to
overwhelm you and
let me invite you to another analysis
board
now as you can see there's only kings
and a pawn left
so a lot of people when they look at a
position like this they assume draw
because
they assume that you cannot win this
game with one pawn that's like on d2
right and pawns are going this way
so believe it or not who's
the side that is to move is the side
that's able to sort of
perform to their desired result if it is
white to move in this position white
wins with best play
if it is black to move in this position
he draws with best play
and i want to show you why and through
that i want to introduce you to one very
very important endgame concept
that concept is called opposition
um now obviously that means absolutely
diddly squats here right now but
well don't be saying that i know what
that means we've gone over opposition
when we did the uh
knight yeah the the rook king checkmate
oh [ __ ] we did yeah that also involves a
foreign holy [ __ ] man i
i underestimated your abilities yet
again
i i apologize okay so mr smarty pants
why don't you go ahead and start to win
this position then
if you know everything about why didn't
you also teach me how to beat you know
hikaru and all of my opponents as well
well think about it i mean you'll have
to pay for my tutoring services of
course
with the pleasure with pleasure so let's
go so let's do the first step first if
it's white to move here
how do you actually claim the opposition
like can you get control of the
opposition here
yeah it's pushing up too right so
that what i mean with opposition is king
opposition it's actually a king move
oh well i mean the only way to get
opposition here though is by going to d3
yes exactly king to d3 that is actually
the only move that wins you the game
really yes and a lot of people when they
look at this position they don't know
the technique they assume that you have
to push the pawn up because that's
ultimately what you have to do in order
to win the game you have to make a queen
so they assume well why don't i start
why am i procrastinating with pushing
the pawn off but
let me first show you what happens when
you first push the pawn up and the rule
of thumb here
is whenever the pawn is in front of the
king that is bad for you
if the pawn is in front of the king that
means the position is no longer winning
and there is one exception to that um
which is you know if the pawn is on the
seventh rank but we'll get to that
so let me let me show you how this
unfolds
okay black ghost king d6 you go king e4
black ghost king e6
you keep pushing the pawn right you keep
pushing the pawn you keep chasing the
king away
everything's going smoothly perfect
perfect i'm about to make a new queen
and then we run into a very interesting
situation
we run into this position and here black
has to be very accurate in order to draw
the game so black has two moves
he has king e8 and he has king d8 one of
those moves loses and one of those moves
draws
i will give you sort of the parameters
that you're trying to fulfill and i want
you to find black's best move
what black has to do is be the one to
step into the opposition
black cannot let white be the one to
step into the opposition so with that in
mind which move do you think black
should play
well then the only move that works there
is d8 right because if you go
e8 he pushes the pawn it puts him in
check and then you go
to d8 which then lets the white king get
into the opposition right um
there was a lot wrong about what you
just said and very little right
so
if you push the pawn up to d7 number one
he can just take the goddamn
not only have you given up jesus and you
know it's like it's like those scenes
where where someone's killed and then
that person comes back and like steps on
him one more time
also given black well i guess black does
have the opposition here as well
so not only have you given up your only
hope to win you have also granted the
opposition to black
yeah um the other one unless you were
well i mean you're maybe you're testing
me actually in some like twisted form of
the word the other problem is if you go
king d6 you can shout to the whole world
that you have opposition but i'm gonna
shout to the whole world that i'm
stalemated
so opposition is only good if your
opponent actually has legal moves that
he can play
okay i can i can make my apartment into
a country and claim that i'm the
president of this country but nobody's
gonna give a [ __ ] just like nobody gives
a [ __ ] about opposition here at
stalemate
does it make sense that it's stalemate
yeah
so the problem with the move d7 is that
well he can take the pawn or he can go
to d8 so i want you to directly grab the
opposition here with white in this
position
so it's just cutting off the pawn minute
d7
right uh i'm looking at to see if you
have the same yeah so wait to move here
what wha what move steps into the
opposition with the king sorry
white's move i thought you were okay i
thought you were still testing me on the
best move for black so it's just coming
here that's you've already failed that's
us so yeah i was wondering where we're
just like you know the midnight express
yeah so you made the right move i see on
your stream it didn't
convey but and and now you win the game
because black has to step out of the
opposition
and now you can make your favorite move
which is what
yeah now we're just pushing the pawn
right pushing the pawn up now you're
basically smoking the king out of its
perch on d8 he has to go to c7 and now
how do you pave the way for the pawn to
go even further forward
i obviously just can't push him do i
bring the king up first
and that speaks to one of the most
important concepts in all end games
which is that the king now acquires
superpowers right
the whole middle game the king is trying
not to get made it but
when most pieces are gone from the board
yes the king is a lame piece but you
still have to use it because that is the
only piece you have at your disposal in
those types of positions
so king activity is a crucial
aspect of the end game you have to keep
your king active in most of these
positions
um so does that kind of intuitively make
sense and then
you know the king moves up and you make
a queen and the game is over
right so there's nothing you can do so
with that in mind
where does black's king then have to go
in this position
in order to avoid that scenario
so we need to claim that first right so
yeah so you need to be the one to step
in that's how you i think you can think
about it to make it easier black needs
to be the one to step into the
opposition with white's king
so it's still it is d8 right like you
have to drop it
okay it is d8 exactly so king e6 is met
with what move
can we go to e8 exactly and white as
per your you know expert opinion can
claim opposition here with king d6 but
this is what
this is now still mate right so this is
the ideal situation for black that white
has to force black either into stalemate
or give up his last pawn
like white can move the king away but
then he gives up the pawn
so the reason why you don't want to keep
your pawn in front of the king is
because eventually by force
you get funneled into this situation you
can shift this pawn to the right you can
shift the spawn to the left it doesn't
matter where you shift the spawn
the same exact rules prevail black has
to be the one to step into opposition
and if he does
the game is then drawn so
to go all the way back to the beginning
why do you need to get into opposition
first to begin
it seems like it only really matters
when you get to the seventh rank so
let's talk about it it's gonna be the
same concept repeated on every rank you
step into the opposition
and you perform a technique called out
shouldering it's almost like the king
has a shoulder and you're shouldering
black seeing away from
its control over certain key squares so
black has
many moves which we'll use the move king
e5 for illustrative purposes
now you can keep dancing around with the
opposition but you're not getting
anywhere
so you have to kind of make some ground
with your king so you go king c4
and your goal is to pave pave the path
for the pawn it's like on rolling the
red carpet with the king you know it's
like the president stepping down from
the plane and the military officer
standing there
that's the role that the king plays with
the pawn the king wants to be to the
side of the pawn ideally
controlling the key squares that the
pawn advances to
that makes sense so how does that
actually work uh let's say black goes
king e4
okay that i guess that's opposition but
it's side opposition it's not important
is it now time to move the pawn and if
so how many squares
outflanking i guess the out shouldering
is i guess the russian term for it
outflanking
yeah so why is there a reason why you
wouldn't push up
two squares because i'm not seeing it
you do push it up two squares i go king
f5
and now this is again an application of
the key principle you could push the
pawn up this technically does win
but for instructional purposes you want
to keep
controlling the squares with the king so
where do you think
white can put his king well you get
opposition there at d5 but it's kind of
a worthless opposition so you just bring
up
d5 exactly and after king e6 you want to
avoid the nightmare scenario if you
bring your pawn up one square the pawn
is on the same rank as the king black's
king gets back to d7 so don't let the
king get back to d7
okay so then we need to cut that off by
bringing the king up to c6
bingo the king goes to e7 now we have a
problem
we bring the pawn up very nice black has
two possible moves that we're going to
analyze king d8 and king
if he goes king d8 we've reached one of
the crucial positions we talked about
now white has to sidestep a mistake and
make
an only move does he get opposition or
does he push the pawn up
opposition right here wouldn't matter
right because our pawn's not in the
not on the right rank for that to be a
player right not your opposition would
matter if you go
d6 is this a familiar situation black is
always got an opposition
you get stalemate again so you do have
to get opposition
and the reason that the reason you get
opposition is because black can't pass
black would like to pass a move here but
he can't he has to move his king to one
of the sides and then you move the
white king to the other side so king e8
is met with what move you go the
opposite direction in order to pave the
way for the pawn now
yeah now we just go back to c6 right but
not c6 because c6 will control the
queening square
c7 and now we can we are safe to do what
and we can basically close our eyes and
do this
now we're just bringing the pawn up all
the way to d8 so this is remember this
is the ideal situation you get the king
on c7
and you have the pawn on d5 and you can
just push it up all the way now
okay same exact thing happens on the
other side of king c8 is played
what does white do here now we're
bringing it to e7 bingo and then
d6 d7 d8 so this is all
it all seems a little detached from
reality but this is all going to make
sense
and it's all going to come together in
your mind trust me
i've taught this one or two times before
and you're doing a good job
you're doing a good job this is hard to
teach actually if you want to know
i'll give you a little insight into the
coaches laboratory
these end games for me are among the
hardest to teach well
because there's so many rules and they
don't all make intuitive sense so i have
to make them all make sense and and then
help you put them all together so if i'm
doing a bad job i want to hear about it
i'm actually not as experienced with
this you see i'm learning too
no i mean that all made sense to me okay
so
i want you to start from and see the pro
another problem another reason this is
hard to teach black has many moves in
any particular positions the rules about
how you play
stay the same but black can sidestep in
various different ways for example let's
say black plays king to d6
white to move try to make a couple of
accurate moves now in this position
okay i'm gonna go king c6
this is where you need to make a really
five-head move
because every fiber in your body is
probably
urging you to push upon two squares yeah
that's exactly what it is not even
looking at your stream but i'm sure
you're hovering over that square right
now
yeah yeah it was right sorry remember
it's not how it looks because now the
pawn and the king are on the same file
that is [ __ ] bad why is it bad
because we've talked about this scenario
before now you start pushing the pawn
the pawn is in front of the king the
worst case scenario
which means black always gets the
opposition here white has no way to
force the opposition then we get the
nightmare scenario
okay so i didn't realize that i was in
perpetuity so if you do get them on the
same
uh the same file there before you get to
the seventh rank it's always going to be
black's opposition
exactly how it works so here
counter-intuitively
you push the pawn not two squares but
one square and the idea is that so you
can then grab the opposition with one
move
yeah now we're just going here to defend
and then you start what's called the
outflanking procedure wherever black's
king move
moves you move to the other side i think
in soccer there exists that very same
concept like i've seen
pretty sure i've seen like lionel messi
do that well he like fakes his opponent
out you go one way and i go the other
way
okay you go what you can actually do
that again
that would be a mistake i get opposition
you want to do that as many times as you
can to pave
as many squares as possible for the pawn
i didn't mean it
oh i see you play king d5 yeah so king
c7
yeah it sometimes auto syncs weird
weirdly
okay king c5 i'm gonna go king d7 we're
gonna keep dancing
you let me into the opposition
you let me enter into opposition so in
this position
sorry in sorry in this position
you need something it's going opposite
you need to keep faking them out you
need to keep going opposite
yeah exactly exactly king e6
all right that makes sense then okay
and the reality is only when you have
and this is i want you to hammer this
rule in your head
only when the king has reached the sixth
rank can you actually start pushing the
pawn
so what that means is king e6 i go king
d8
now you don't need to do that thing one
more time you can actually start pushing
the pawn
and that's because you have no tiles to
drop back on right exactly
exactly that's just the way the geometry
of the board works and you can actually
push the pawn all the way to d7
you don't have to here you can do that
outflanking procedure again i want you
to actually
do that perform that outflanking
procedure
yep and if the king goes to e8
okay you're learning this pretty fast
but because the king has reached the
sixth rank there's another cool thing
you can do
which is actually no can you push the
pawn to d6
is that a possible move sorry i actually
miscalculated this at first
yeah because you can't grab opposition
right i mean you can
but it's not going to be calculated
calculate this out until the end so king
e8
what does white do
wait what movie is being played right
now uh let's say black goes king to e8
so who wins does white win or is this a
draw
push the pawn and charge the pawn shack
king d8
yeah and then d8 yeah that's just going
to be a draw then that's a stalemate
right then i can't leave that's exactly
right so instead of this you have to go
king d8 you have to pave the way but
what you can do is
you orchestrate this procedure until the
king is on the sixth rank
then you can push the pawn up to the
fifth rank and then you can do the same
thing again
okay okay now there's another one more
interesting thing which is that
if you push the pawn up to the fifth
rank um
sorry let me just i'm just making a
bunch of random moves for illustrative
purposes
i'm just trying to get the right
situation here so here
here here here here i keep
so we need the king and he we need this
position with white to move okay so
sorry
yeah so in this position sorry that took
me a long time to actually do
this is one of the exceptions to the
rope black grabs opposition while the
pawn is on the fifth rank
white actually can't push the pawn up
two squares and win the game because
what happens is we'll try it
try it yeah you only have one move right
you can only do one move back and forth
right now i go here we had this before
now you can you can
control the promoting square with your
king exactly indeed clean yeah
so there's really three i guess we can
break this down it's a three
three separate processes one is out
flanking where you claim opposition and
then you go the opposite way to pave
more squares for that pawn to go you do
that until the king reaches the sixth
rank
then you push the pawn up to the fifth
rank and depending where black's king is
you either push it all the way to the
seventh rank or you do that procedure
one more time to control the final
promoting squares
now you might ask well why don't we just
[ __ ] get this over with until the
very why don't we just get it over with
here why don't we just like do this and
then this
right you know what you see what i'm
saying and then this and
the problem is well you could do that
the problem is the pawn is now a little
bit too far away
so black goes king e7 you go d4 and
black goes king e6 and all of a sudden
he catches the pawn
so that's why you want to stop when
you're here
and then start pushing the pawn up to
the fifth ring so that the king can't
catch the pawn
so that's why you do those things in
that order okay that makes sense so it's
very tricky you know but
let's try to do it from the start and i
guarantee you the things are gonna just
all all of them are gonna come together
you do this once and you'll never forget
it again i want you to start from this
position
and try to win the game with white okay
are you seeing the moves or not because
i feel like i just got left on red
yeah you did get left on red but i i i'm
reading your actual stream as well so
it should eventually synchronize
okay for now i'm just manually executing
the moves
okay there we go
just yeah oh okay now you have
opposition
to the procedure yeah yeah but you've
been doing a great job so far
um sorry that scream was unwarranted
it also desync the game you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] what did i do it
unsettled that
you know i i don't even know what to
compare it to there's like uh
gerbils running that are that are
keeping this running and i scared them
off
um yeah now i'm at the sixth rank now i
push it up
i don't know if i'm ever going to give
you another lesson again you know i'm
not appreciating spoken to like that
well that's what you signed up for six
rank opposition is not a problem
exactly i like that you actually grasp
that but this is where you need to be
very careful
yeah that's the third step you want to
perform that procedure again
surgery and now the surgery is over
yeah black has been successfully
lobotomized then you promote the queen
very nice very very nice now the one
comment i wanted to make you actually
did this in the very five head manner
here you played d3
you don't need to do that you can go
king to c5 and you can continue the
procedure and
if king e5 here you make what move
here there's side opposition so you can
you can already start pushing the pawn
up two squares
right okay one move in this position
do i just bring the pawn up again
because on the same file wouldn't matter
in this position
it does it's not on the sixth rank yet
then king goes back to d7
we have the fifth rank so here you have
to continue that procedure until you're
on the sixth rank
right right right right right okay so
then i'm just bringing the king up to c6
yes exactly king c6 king e7
now complete the process okay now this
is when we just push it up because we're
on the sixth rank yeah or do i just want
to keep doing the procedure now
we run into a situation i painted to
earlier like the king tries to catch the
pawn
so you have to push the pawn up one more
square and then complete the procedure
got it okay yep exactly like king e8
beautiful so you got it done you got it
down now now do you see why
um in the starting position
if it were black to move here what move
would black play now
i'm gonna get this position with black
to play
using something called triangulation
okay black to move
solved
now try to draw this with black
yeah now i'm just grabbing opposition
right exactly
and basically you're keeping the king as
close as possible to the bun you're
never going backward when that's
unwarranted
you're staying as close as possible
exactly nice nice nice
yeah because i'm looking for a stalemate
right exactly and this is the only
position where you have to be careful
you have to yep
nice and fast too yeah no i think i
i think i understand this positioning
now because now this is still made very
very nice you got it down for both
colors
now i'm going to blow your mind a little
bit this is actually very easy to
understand
there's only one scenario where all of
this is void null and void
that is if you have a corner pawn and
you'll actually see the reason for this
very very quickly if i
translate this position like three
squares to the left and i get a corner
pawn
okay i'm actually going to do that right
now using
several magical devices that i have at
my disposal
mod tools or whatever you will see and
the chat will be so
just enthralled by what the
transformation that's about to happen on
your screen that they'll all abandon you
i'll have 5 000 subs gifted right about
now
um just one of the booms kind of moves
countdown from five kind of move that
just steals the soul from your wallet eh
exactly exactly the credit cards are out
in force and here we go whoa look at
this guy
it's what a transformation right this
should be in the louvre museum
okay um so it doesn't matter whose move
it is this is a draw it doesn't matter
how many freaking pawns there are on the
a file it's a draw and the reason why is
because unfortunately there's no
letter before a so you have opposition
again you can cry to your
you know you can shout to the world that
you have opposition but
you can't move the king to that blue
part um
or in your case the black part you see
what i'm saying you cannot perform the
outflanking procedure because there's no
airspace
you know there's no real estate to do it
in
that's interesting so in this position
is it best just to
force the stalemate or offer a draw
offer a draw or force the sale mate yeah
most people like they
they might play along and they might
blah blah blah blah blah blah
i mean they might do all of this but
then eventually they for stalemate
and the funny thing is and and it blows
a lot of people's minds but the reality
is there's nothing impressive about this
concept at all
i can set up this position one second
i'm pasting it in
and it's just as much of a draw as
as as any other position um this one
this is also a draw now in the old days
if you ran this position on an engine or
in a computer
it would say that white is completely
winning because white is up five pawns
holy [ __ ]
but then you look at it and the reality
is you cannot this doesn't give you any
added power to what you can do you can
defend the pawn
but you won't be able to smoke black's
king out of the corner square again
because there's no
real estate there's only stalemate
you see what i'm saying yeah so
yeah all of what i just taught you is
only valid from the b to the g
file on the a and h files it's almost
like one of those things like newton's
theory is invalid at like high speeds or
whatever that's where einstein comes in
on the a and h files
the rules of the end game work
completely differently so anything that
i tell you about the end game as we go
forward
usually if we translate whatever i say
to the corner files
things work completely differently by a
completely different set of rules
um so does that sort of make sense
yeah it makes sense to me i'm just
trying to look at ways that maybe
it's not a draw but there's really no
way of planting your king on b7 or
anything is there
even if black is like a monkey this is a
draw like the only circumstance under
which black does not actually
draw is if he deliberately plays king to
c8
in panics thanks uh horse for the for
the sub the kind message yeah yeah
exactly
so king a8 and you can start giving away
your puns now we get a very very funny
scenario
where black just mows down each pawn in
succession and white's king has to stand
and watch
this is like the best example of like
big dick small dig i've ever seen
like white just has to like go around
and watch
as black just gobbles everything up this
is like stealing your lunch money kind
of king
except in chess you want to do that
that's adorable man all right
all right so pawn on the rim is grim as
well
when it comes to in game pawn on the rim
is grim just like knights exactly
so that is your introduction to what's
called theoretical end games
these are like the openings of the end
game you know openings are studied by
people
these end games have been studied by
people and so
the techniques of winning them and
drawing them are already known to the
world
and um there have been hundreds of books
written on these types of end games
which you kind of have to study and
memorize you have to memorize a ton of
these end games because they actually
arise in your games
um for you you don't get a lot of end
games so this might be a little bit less
central
but when you improve at chess when you
improve on end games
you also learn a lot of themes that you
can then apply in middle games and
openings as well
that makes sense how many at the grand
master level how many of them come down
to an end game
um i'm sure that some that would
actually be a very interesting
statistical question
um i would say probably at least like
one and five
okay so it is still pretty sizable i can
actually
i'm looking at my games right now and i
can tell you the longest game
i ever played on record and i've
probably played longer games that are
not in my database
145 moves
holy [ __ ] this game lasted this was in
vegas 2014. i was playing another grand
master from china
this was an endgame and let me paste
this game and i i can show you what end
game this reached 145 was yeah that was
definitely
the longest game in chess history and
recorded chess history i think was 249
moves
well computers so computers play those
constantly though right like most
computer games are like 200 300 moves
right
exactly because the mark the advantages
are so marginal that it takes so long to
like flesh everything out
not 200 300 but computer games regularly
go out to 100 plus games because they
also never agree to draws
you know what i'm saying they always
play it out until the end
so by definition you're going to have
longer games i don't know if you see me
pasting it
no oh that well i see the uh five
pawns oh god yeah it's one of those
things um i'm going to have to close
that board
close that board thank you bulldozer
abandoned for this room
yeah i'm going to try to yeah with pgns
for some reason it doesn't uh
okay let me let me try to reinvite you
one sec
plus turbo if it doesn't work then
yeah well i'll just paste the position
okay i got it
let's see i'm looking at your stream to
see what you see
yep [ __ ] you saw it and then it
disappeared
like it was there for a flashing moment
and then now you see like the original
game
this isn't the one yeah like on your
stream it briefly showed up and then it
disappeared
um you can invite me again i guess
try one more time if it doesn't work
i'll just show you the final position
sorry for the
that's all good man um let me close out
of it myself
and the chess.com devs have been on this
for years it doesn't quite seem to be a
fixable problem
um okay i think i've accidentally
spoiled the season finale
is the end game with a black one rook
one bishop yes exactly
that's exactly it so set position pgn
and now let me invite you one more time
if not i'll just
i'll just uh paste in the final position
to show you what what the end game was
okay let's see all right well well now
you see it
this is it okay you wait the last game
that you had could you
could you open that other one up like
you have two games open right now could
you open the other one up
yeah like it's on the right hand toolbar
yes that's it that's it
yeah that's it um so that was
[ __ ] hell okay
so i guess um there's some sort of weird
delay um but basically
this was like the type of end game that
we had reached
um and we played this position out for
another 60 moves
and basically i was black so i had the
rook and the bishop and he had the rook
in the pawn i went as pawn eventually
and that is a theoretical draw so that
position despite
black having an extra bishop with best
defense is a draw black does not have
enough resources to win
and it's considered to be one of the
hardest draws to make in chess from a
human perspective
and my freaking opponent sat there and
defended it for two plus hours and made
that draw
and i made him work for every [ __ ]
penny we finished at about 3am and guess
what happened at 9 00 a.m the next day
the next damn game yeah baby life of a
chess player so
this was 149 moves and i've had a couple
of games lasting over 100
uh over 100 moves um 128 moves in spain
i had a game
yeah so 108 moves i had about maybe 10
or 15 games so sorry that was a very
long-winded answer to your question but
essentially lots of games reach the end
game end games are a crucial phase
of the game tons of books have been
written on end games
i've dabbled in that as well but again
it's primary use it says
toilet paper but and get you know it's
like it's like the
going to the dents like you have to do
it um and there's no way around it if
you're a strong player
tons of your games reach the end game
because the differences in strength
between you and your opponent just
aren't that fast
sorry i feel like i talked like 45
minutes just now
no you're all good did you change the
position or
no i just okay it's not working because
like i'm looking at your stream and you
see the correct position but
i'm not able to make any moves but we
just made like 50 random moves here i
tortured him forever
i can see some of them you wait did you
guys chase kings around oh yeah you
can't see them
wait no no it's like super glitchy it's
like
super imposing one game on top of
another game like this is so weird
no no no we didn't have this we didn't
have this we played with rook and bishop
against king
you're clicking on the top computer line
so it's just telling you like king moves
this is fascinating keep doing this
i'm watching your stream and i want to
see how this ends up i don't know
well it doesn't they just go endlessly
forever no i was
i was sarcastic [ __ ] oh okay i was
gonna say you've got a weird fetish
uh yeah for uh oh those bear king
positions oh man
show me more of them it is it's 46 moves
of just king positions
that's a folder on my computer i don't
let anybody access just like segments of
games that had bear kings
i know just don't don't mention this
denim anybody because
i cherish it with all of my heart
so yeah this is just fascinating
i can't even look at your stream i might
lose it so i need to switch to
my own yeah i don't know how to find
your moves but it showed me a couple of
moves there before
yeah exactly but you get the hang of it
it was like just tons of long games
in the longest game in history over 200
moves um went into the next
day um and like tempers tempers flare up
when you play these long games
like i remember there was some like
like the longer the game goes the more
annoyed like when your opponent sniffles
or something the more annoyed you get
um and then obviously the next day
you're just a zombie um so tournaments
are just thankless thankless things
so did you not have like a time limit or
did you manage to play like
100 whatever moves in that time limit so
the thing is
um this tournament was played with an
increment so every move you made you
added an additional 30 seconds on your
clock this is actually
the drawback of increment because you
can basically play these endless games
and your time doesn't run out
we were also playing for a ton of money
the top prize in this tournament was a
hundred thousand dollars
this was called the millionaire chess
challenge it was one of the few
open tournaments with such a big prize
and
there were like hundreds and hundreds of
competitors tons of grand masters
and the final the top four participants
the top four players in the standings at
the end of seven games
they went into the final four to
basically play for the big prizes
and i showed this on my stream but i
qualified i
tied for fourth place after seven games
with four other grand masters
so that very same evening this is like
24 hours after this massive
long game was played we played a
tiebreaker mini tournament to see who
would get that fourth spot
and i choked on the crucial game that
was the one of the only time this was
covered on air this was live streamed
i've shown my stream like the actual
game
on tape like me actually playing that
crucial tiebreaker game and i actually
accidentally accidentally i i lost it um
so i didn't quite qualify for the final
four
that pain was unlike anything you just
expect it's like
crushing absolutely crushing ah that
sounds
miserable yeah fourth place would have
been what like 20 grand uh i would be
guaranteed at least 20 grand yeah if i
qualified into the final four so i lost
about fifth that was the most money i've
ever lost with one chess game i lost
about
i think my final prize in the end was
about 5k so i lost
at least 15k with one with like three
moves
so you know the people who think chess
is just like a
not high stakes game like like take that
as an example of
of why chess players are stressed all
the time
yeah yeah well i mean chess has a
like good sponsors and stuff right like
i know it's a kind of a meme but hikaru
is allegedly worth 44 million dollars so
we'll put it this way the top of the top
make a good living so the top 10 chess
players in the world make a good
delivery but then it like
asymptotically goes down like for me if
i were to only play in tournaments and i
weren't and i would not coach i would
not stream
i would basically be on the streets of
charlotte
the reality is a lot of european players
eastern european players are able to
make a living because the salaries there
are obviously they can win
one or two tournaments a year 10 15 k
and that's enough for them to survive in
america
unfortunately chess at the grassroots
level at the level of 100
100th in the world where i am
approximately very very
you know you have to make a living as a
coach you have to kind of be a chess
businessman or other stuff so there are
sponsors it's getting better
but i would say it's still nowhere near
other sports
that makes sense yeah yeah
so well this is fascinating i mean if
you have any other questions that would
happen answer i was thinking maybe we
could finish off with like one or one or
two games
in the tournament yeah we'll hop in the
pool um but i love talking about this as
you can tell like i
i i feel like i'm going out too i'm
probably boring the hell out of your
chat but
uh no man i think most people find it
interesting
it's a perspective you don't typically
get to hear yeah
yeah it's a very niche niche just like
bear king fetishes it's a very niche
field
okay so you're playing caledonian 87
does that guy have any teeth jesus
yeah people in your chat are too kind to
me i'm just seeing the outpouring of
support
yeah so that's a good question from the
chat though who did win the 100k
guy named wesley so he is now ranked in
the top 10
in the world um and back then he was
also ranked in the top 10 in the world
so the basically the pre-tournament
favorite one
but i don't quite remember is this best
to just chase that away at a3 or just
keep developing he's indirectly
attacking your e4 pawn he wants to
remove its defender
by capturing your knight so you have to
lend further reinforcement
to the pawn on e4 right okay so then it
is still just developing where i push
this pawn up to d3 here and then
look to develop bishop next yep exactly
exactly right
okay well he's he's very proud of
himself that he ruined your pawn
structure but that again we discussed
this he's also given up a very important
bishop
yeah okay so yeah so now i'm just
looking to
bring bishop either do i want to bring
bishop back because holding this
knight pin doesn't do me much good which
we've gone over so i just want to bring
it back to b3 right missing the forest
for the trees though he's also attacking
your pawn on e4
twice and you're only defending it once
so you actually have to release the
tension here
really okay so i just have to take the
pawn then yes
yeah otherwise he wins the prawn he
takes the pawn with his phone and then
he takes that with it with his knight
okay that makes sense yeah i guess i
just didn't even notice that
right now he's attacking your pawn on c3
you can make a really five head move and
sacrifice it for developments
that would be the next level of play
stacking the pawn to develop yeah so
just basically proceeding as if nothing
is happening and just continuing to
develop
because also notice if he takes the pawn
that puts his knight on an awkward
square
where you could attack it with your
queen so
okay so bishop g5 he goes wow he's
playing instantly
so in this position here uh dropping it
back i could get trapped because he does
have that pawn that he could eventually
get to f4
so drop it back such that it also
defends the c3 pawn
yeah so then i just want to bring this
bad boy back all the way to here
nice now you have the two bishops you've
weakened his position
he's pushed to spawn out to f6 he's
playing very well so far but you can
keep developing
yeah uh so him now pushing this bishop
uh what does this do
when he well he can't really move this
night anywhere where he doesn't get
taken so the night's not going anywhere
keep developing what's up keep
developing
yeah so now i just want a castle bingo
so this is um okay queen e7
um
so i'll tell you what i was looking at
uh so it looks i think he's gonna want
to castle
uh long here yeah i was looking at just
bringing rook to b1 preemptively and
maybe forcing him the castle short where
it's weaker
love it love it love it love that's a
great that's a great move putting the
rook on an open file he might still
castle along
and defend that pawn okay he doesn't
okay but now he's
his knight on c6 has lost its support so
you
have the option of attacking it yeah so
now i can just bring my bishop over here
to b5 which
now pins it and he has nothing to defend
it he'll have to move either his bishop
yeah and that introduces more
awkwardness in his position you could
maybe attack the other
night with your pawn i mean things start
to roll downhill for him here
already
okay okay so he's defending uh what i
was looking at next
is bringing my pawn on c3 up to c4
attacking the knight but more so
bringing up the diagonal for my bishop
at d2 to attack queen
that's all exactly right bingo
sorry i got excited but that like both
of the moves the follow-up moves and
also bishop to b4 noticing that he can't
take that bishop with his knight
because that knight is pinned so once
this other knight moves that square is
free to go to
exactly perfect and you've noticed how
you put your rook on b1
now it serves the purpose of supporting
that bishop otherwise he would have
taken it with his queen
and now focus on that knight on c6 you
want that knight
to lose its support so think about what
you want to do next
right so i'm imagining he's going to
yeah so now he has that knight only
defended by that one nights and i just
want to take
knight with bishop and then i win a king
all right
you win the king can you tell me about
how to win kings because i really want
to know that
again you'll have to pay for my tutoring
services
maybe you'll cut me a discount i'll
think about it i'll think about it
i'd be honored so very nice this was
like a great stretch of play this is
like how i would have done it there
should be five c4 bishop before it takes
e7 you see how harmonious your play has
become
and yeah i really think i genuinely
think like taking breaks in between has
been great to like refresh my [ __ ]
eyes the hunger is there and like your
training is more targeted
and you're just playing great i mean
you're finding all these ideas
but it's also like not about the
quantity i never trained for more than
like an hour a day
so i went to school you know i had
basketball and [ __ ] so like i always
don't buy this thing where people say oh
you have to train seven eight hours a
day
you just have to train well chess is not
a game okay what the hell
he doesn't even take your bishop back
yeah so
that's probably the best move for him
right otherwise i was gonna win a rook
out of that too
so now i just need to drop my bishop
back to keep that out of harm's way
now does it matter what square i put
them on between b4 and
a3 the less contacts the better so put
it on a square where it's safe you
you've gotten the kill
just just bring it back you know shelter
that bishop because there's a
you know yeah okay so i'm just gonna
bring it back to b4 then
okay i would bring it to a3 less contact
means before bishop is pressured by his
knight now you say the knight can't move
yes but why open up that possibility
even later you know what i'm saying
okay that's fair all right that makes
sense bingo bishop a3
okay i'm looking to chase away bishop to
go ahead and move
move it and so now i'm just bringing
back to a4 i'll still hold this and then
i'll just end up dropping him back
anyway
so he can't trap it or anything because
i have a pawn protecting it
he made a nice move here actually b5
bishop d3 good
so he's he's pressuring your pieces but
he can't win them and you've already
you're already a piece up
and he also can't castle because of that
other bishop on a3
okay now he's bonded upon
yeah so this move right here is there
any reason why he played that or is that
just a [ __ ] move all around
it's a [ __ ] move all around okay
i imagine maybe he wants to take bishop
with bishop
might be his thought yeah but then you
have an intermediate move you could make
you could there's in it okay he doesn't
do that now again prioritize
the immediacy what is his most annoying
piece
oh well right now that knight on d4
that's a good
[ __ ] get the hell out of there so
that we can clear our head and think
also he loses another piece but i don't
know if you actually see that at this
point he's just blundered another piece
by him moving that knight he's blundered
a piece yeah but go ahead and you know
remove the vermin okay so what i was
thinking of
uh i was just going to push my c pawn up
i was going to use c3 which also do that
when you can take the knight
i guess i was just thinking a little
longer term where i could develop my
queen going out to the c
diagonal or up to the diagonal through
that c2
but maybe that's not worth it's not
worth it and
once you take the night you will see why
it's best to take the night whenever you
capture a night like this you have to
understand the consequences he can only
capture the night with a pawn right
because
well never mind apparently he thinks
better but what is he allowing you to do
he's just blended his bishop with that
yep exactly and had he taken the knight
with a pawn he would have opened up the
e
file you could have put a rook on the e
file and won his bishop anyway
gotcha okay so that's why it was better
to take understanding reminding yourself
one of the key takeaways from today's
session reminding yourself
to check how the position changes when
there is some sort of capture you know
what i'm saying
any capture in the center of the board
especially
are there any files that are opened are
there any pieces that are left
undefended are there any squares that i
can now occupy
stuff like that is is something you have
to sort of mechanistically check for
right yeah he's just uh cursing his fate
right now he also can't castle
either side because both bishops like
respectively the dark and the light
squared bishop are
stop stopping him from castling short
and long it's crazy yeah
this is a really nice position to be in
so i'm thinking of follow-ups right now
yeah good
uh since my queen my queen's still on
this diagonal where i can deliver a
check
i'm just trying to see where i would go
from there um
and you can actually you're actually
thinking in the right direction
don't tunnel vision this yeah old
charlie would just move the bishop
but the new you can actually take this
one step further and you can
counter-attack him
and make a stronger threat
yes i think this is still my original
idea right i haven't finished like
processing where it goes from here but
delivering that check over there at h5
he blocks what'd you say go ahead you
can do that first and then and
sorry don't wrap so you blotch with the
pawn and then we'll think but this is a
good move
now think about where you can drop this
queen to make another threat
look at the whole board don't just look
near his king's side
yeah um so i can threaten that rook all
the way back there
at a8 which is what i looked at and then
also even if you move to that rook that
still gives me a hanging pawn then i can
attack on f6 oh and that's exactly why
giving the check on h5 is such a good
idea preliminarily because you soften up
the f6 pawn
that is called provoking a weakness that
is a seriously high level idea now
collect
yeah so now he's [ __ ] up he didn't
even see this yeah but he's already
[ __ ] either way
now you take not only one rope and he
resigned what a beautiful game so
um to finish off there's a couple of
observations i want to make here i can
invite you to an analysis board but this
was amazing unless you want to play one
more game in lieu of that
no you can toss me i want to see what uh
maybe i missed yeah so there's there's
this is like
again the next level of chess
understanding um you're not giving these
guys any chances but there's a few
things i wanted to clarify okay inviting
you right now
okay invited so
i'm in basically yeah so d3 this move
makes sense now right you have to lend
support to the spawn
yeah so i wasn't sure what
like was was concerning you here but
like bishop b3 he just takes the pawn
and if you take the pawn yeah i guess he
just takes the queen and takes the fun
out he's forking these other two pawns
this is just bad for white
yeah i guess i don't i'm not really sure
i guess i was just so preoccupied with
now my bishops hanging because i didn't
have that support
so still another form of like tunnel
vision one could say like you see the
bishop being hang you're like i have to
drop my bishop but
forcing yourself to look at the whole
board here like you know the usual
um so it takes takes so here
there's two things again i think
sometimes in your mind you overestimate
the development of the bishops to g5 and
b5
this was not one of those cases because
luckily you can retreat the bishop back
to d2
but normally you want to be careful
about a move like this which can be just
blocked by a pawn
you know what i'm saying yeah okay so
what i would have done here is just
castled and the idea is very simple if
he takes on c3 with a knight you can
fork this knight and another pawn
which queen move does that job i mean
you only have two of them so
yeah we're just going to e1 right away
now you take on e5 and his king gets
opened up and he's not castled yet i
could even
delay taking this pawn and go bishop a3
with the idea of stopping him from
castling
so this is what's called compensation
this is when you've sacrificed upon
but you have so many advantages in
return that it's more than worth
so i would do this and that's because i
just i've played so many of these games
that to me
when i see a thread against my pawn i
like brush it off like a bug on my
shoulder you know it's like not a
problem
so i draw the line at threats against my
pieces when a bishop is being threatened
then i bat an eye when a pawn is being
threatened
oftentimes you can just go along with
your business but
this move was amazing this move was
amazing c4 bishop before this is truly
an advanced idea so you've been finding
more of these which is great
thanks man yeah i was pretty proud of
that one i actually calculated that [ __ ]
kind of deep so i'm glad it had done
that i saw this this
this unorthodox development of the
bishop which is great so
one last thing i want to point out about
this game is that um
why is bishop a3 better than bishop
before so this is this concept of
contact
what you see is well he can't take my
bishop with his knight because i take
the queen but again
this is a case where i'm thinking in the
long run and maybe you're thinking a
little bit in the short term
see i'm envisioning a scenario where
let's say he pushes this bishop away
from b5
let me give you an example let's say the
same thing would have happened is in the
game a6
bishop a4 b5 and you bring the bishop
back to b3 now you see the drawback of
putting the bishop on b4 what is it
yeah he just takes the bishop he just
takes the bishop so i'm taking care
again on my future self but just tucking
it away in a square
where it's not making contact with any
of my opponent's pieces it's done its
job it's taken the night
now tuck it away park it somewhere safe
away from the
the danger and other than that i mean
everything was great bishop queen h5 was
a great check provoking g6
you could have gone queen f3 immediately
but this is even stronger
the last thing i want to mention is in
this position
and this will i think be a good way to
finish off in the theme
of today's concept white to play and
check made in two moves don't tunnel
vision this pawn on f6 you have
something even better
yeah so i'm thinking instead of taking
this pawn he's moved his rooks on that
winning rook is it bringing the queen
over here to c6 i deliver a check
that now yeah that forces him here and
then this is checkmate right bingo nice
and you saw that instantly once again
that's just representative of the
improvement queen f3
queen c6 and instead he resigned because
you actually to add insult to injury
take another rook
yeah and then you're up a million pieces
so i'm thinking next time we can work a
little bit on your technique and sort of
revisit where that is
winning these types of positions a
little bit more smoothly i think you
need some work in that area
but the order of operations so to speak
has gotten much better
your crispness with tactics is
incomparably better and i think yes if
you get a chance to solve some problems
on your own
checking those checkmate boxes i think
that's the area where i think you need
maybe the most improvement but
by and large i mean amazing i think the
the combination you produce in the
beginning
and uh this game as well uh it's going
great i think you're very much prepared
for twitch rivals
you are participating in twitch rivals
right yeah
yeah so i you know i don't even know my
own role i think uh
you know it'll be a bit of a
free-for-all with the with the streamers
but i think you're very much well
prepared and uh
you know maybe we can fit one more
session in uh but if not obviously
there's pock jams too and uh
we'll be we'll be in touch so how do you
feel how did this uh
how was the session for you do you have
any questions anything on your mind
no man it's always fun and informative i
think you're a great teacher
and it's always a good time man are you
gonna be doing more of your goofy
[ __ ] anime dances tonight uh maybe a
little bit yeah i'll go for another 30
minutes or so
all right yeah i'll probably keep going
as well yep i yeah
sounds great so uh process all of that a
lot of stuff to
internalize well you have a fantastic
rest of your stream
and uh very good very good work today
i'm i'm
rough on the exterior but i'm i'm
[ __ ] proud so
rest assured thanks all right i
appreciate it man this is great
have a great rest of your stream and a
great night you too man i'll talk to you
soon
we'll be in touch sounds great bye
all right you guys well that was uh
another very productive i would say very
productive session i mean the
improvement is unbelievable this is
again i haven't coached as many
beginners but
this improvement is as fast as anything
i've seen i mean he's playing like 16
1700 level games